you ever chop it up with Joe Budden I  know you had felt some type of way about  some of the things you may or may not  have said I'm gonna talk to Joe Budden  when I see him  because I don't like playing that not on  some like not on some like rah-rah [ __ ]  just like you know I'm gonna talk to him  when I see him though we definitely  because you guys have a good at least  you have a great relationship he's  called you live on the podcast we cool  but we definitely gonna have to have a  concert when I see him we don't have to  have a private conversation I feel like  a lot of the content and I think that I  owe him that yeah and I think a lot of  the context of like the situation that  people have opinions about they don't  it's a couple [ __ ] I gotta have  a problem it ain't the only one right  you know what I'm saying but yeah I  gotta have we gotta we need to have a  private conversation now just leave it  at that but you know all love and  blessings down